on Saturday the presidency of Donald
Trump passed the 100 day mark meaning
this prank has officially gone on for
way too long with the Donald unable to
get much of his agenda through Congress
he's fallen back and what he does best
both think about how great he is if the
bass just ask him in fact though the
next presidential election is still 3
and 1/2 years away this 2020 campaign is
spending 1.5 million dollars to run this
ad touting his accomplishments Donald
Trump sworn in as president 100 days ago
America has rarely seen such success
destructive Supreme Court justice
confirmed companies investing in
American jobs again doesn't that sounds
like the action news guy voice doesn't
it wasn't the only newsworthy piece of
video about the hundred day milestone
and yet another instance of the most
over reported political story of the
year
ABC went to the Midwest check in with
working-class voters you had to give a
grade what would it be um I think I
would give them a B+ people I like that
twittering this week bother you well I
don't really read them so it's only a
matter of time before Trump responds on
Twitter hey old bag and a diner who
gives me a B+ I'll give your dumb
sweater an F Titanic lady yeah you
should have followed that necklace down
on the bottom of the ocean oh I'm still
tweeting I'm right out of characters uh
comedians what grade would you give
President Trump on his first hundred
days partes well they grade restaurants
a to d so I'd have to give Trump
Chipotle all right boys Annamarie hey he
is sort of skating by on Obama's
accomplishments anyway alright boys
under Gina what's the grade you'd give
dog meat how about this president is in
nothing but lips an asshole all right
[Applause]